when I have my helmet on and I'm out on
track you can't tell my gender you can't
tell what I look like all that matters
is my performance my name is Susie Wolff
and I am development driver for the
Williams martini racing Formula One team
I started racing at eight because I
loved racing I never sit out on a path
to prove people wrong that women could
compete at the pinnacle of motorsport I
simply found my passion in life there is
nothing that comes close to drive in a
Formula One car when I get in the car my
helmets on the visor comes down that is
such a pure feeling you're pushing
yourself to your absolute limit out on
track you're searching for every one
hundredth of a second I think i'm
generally often underestimated people
see me as a little blonde girl running
through the paddock think she can drive
a Formula One car and that's why for me
performance is so important there are
more and more women in Formula One on
and off the track when it's happening in
a very organic way and nobody is pushing
the women and they're coming because
they're very good at what they do if
they would ever consider an only female
championship it wouldn't be what I would
want to race them at all no I've been
racing since every day against men and
it's been successful the goal is without
a doubt just in Formula One it's tough
because there are so many young very
talented drivers who are fighting their
way to the top so you really have to be
aware that you have tough competition